j'avais jamais vu une chose pareille
auparavant au moment de sa mort cet
homme était âgé de 3 ans
ça coince oui c'est au sujet de votre
frère qu'il a disparu ou gens vous
retrouvez l'udc mais j'ai besoin de
votre aide
il ya un problème elle sera de catégorie
4 quand elle frappera avec de puissants
vents de sable
je la vois elle est gigantesque mine
abandonnée un kilomètre environ 13 ans
est présent
à
mais on dirait une sorte de caverne à en
croire la légende on à creuser une tombe
il ya plus de 2000 ans dans ce secteur
certainement l'endroit idoine ya toi tu
d'entonnoir l'a mordu mais ces araignées
là sont mortelles
[Applaudissements]
garçons désolé j'ai oublié de commander
un torrent de lave incandescente milli
[Applaudissements]
vous devriez partir
nous nous trouvons devant une découverte
archéologique majeure une fois par an
elle se créteil dans ses mains c'est
vraiment miraculeux la fontaine de
jouvence du génie génétique
ces araignées ont été conçus pour leur
production et l'assassinât vous pensez
être dieu pour vous amuser avec la vie
des gens peuvent vous n'avez rien
compris il parce que c'est toi
jack saisonniers peuvent survivre soul
ou j'aime pas trop les araignées mois
[Applaudissements]